[Música]
ele quer que eu reitero porque o esporte
que eu pratico desde os 8 anos de idade
e é ao longo do tempo praticando com que
eu percebi que traz bastante benefícios
para as pessoas da 1 surgiu o confundiu
da china da observação dos animais foi
traduzido para o brasil no final da
década de 60 pode ser praticado por
qualquer uma
homens mulheres crianças e até idosos
agora eu vou falar um pouco mais sobre
os benefícios à criatividade cada
movimento do copom foi inspirado em um
animal são eles caixa serpente dragão
tigre e pantera a concentração
esse esporte requer muita concentração
pois imagino se a professora faz uma
seqüência de movimentos e você está
olhando para os lados
na hora que você pôr em prática você não
vai fazer saber fazer nada aliás você
tava olhando para os lados
o respeito toda vez que nós entramos na
sala para praticar kung fu nós temos que
fazer um sinal de respeito para o nosso
professor chamado quem likes mas assim o
equilíbrio como flex pais que auxilia no
equilíbrio do corpo e no equilíbrio da
mente
aqui se alguns outros objetos
essa é a roupa do corpo flur e aqui
estão algumas outras armas mas lembrando
o conflito não é esporte para aprender a
luta mas sim para a primeira defesa
pessoal
obrigado pela atenção
[Aplausos]
[Música]